liberty
thank you all for uh wanting to join the
labor committee it's not for everybody
so i appreciate those wanting to come
back
and those who chose it and even some who
i've spoken to that didn't show
choose it but are in the committee
anyway
the schedule today um is going to be
um the first 30 minutes will be um
some general conversation with us as the
members there's a brief introduction
some information that i can provide to
us
at 10 30 we'll have the department of
employment securities with
uh commissioner corporos and ladders
followed
following at 11 o'clock representative
infantine you do need to read the script
uh for the public meeting do you have
that
i did but no in mind let me i will email
it to you right now
please email it to us gosh please email
it not to my representative one but my
other email your work
oh
hey you'll just have to put your uh
committee name in there i apologize that
my computer's now making sure that your
would you like me to read it from the
top line as chair
yes please okay folks as chair of the
house labor committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
a result of covid19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
and confirming that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate controversially
and temporarily within this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by
zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access
information has been made available to
the house in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for the committee meeting
notice complies with the house and rsa
91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
email should
call 271 3600
or email hcs
ledge dot state
dot nh dot u s
that again is if you have any problems
you should call 271
3600 or email hcs
ledge dot state dot nh dot u
the event the public is unable to access
the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christina dyer committee researcher will
be the staff assistant
staff assisting us please note that all
votes that are taken during the meeting
shall be done by roll call
vote let's start take by start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states your presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during your meeting
law
we have the clerk call the roll
certainly uh
chairman william infantine are you alone
etc
i'm here and i'm alone uh
brian seaworth i'm here and i'm alone
myself i am here i'm alone uh leno
alvaloni
john callum
[Music]
mark warden i'm in my office by myself
i'm here okay leonard turcotte
i am here my wife is at the other end of
right i am here
and i am joined by my two labrador
retrievers
brian sullivan here in my home office
alone
tim susie i'm here um and my daughter is
in the kitchen
even soon benjamin broody
i am here with my four-legged friend
i'm home in new market my wife is
elsewhere in the building
linda de salvestro i am here i am alone
jan schmidt i am present i am in my own
donald bouchard i'm here at home and
home joshua archerton
president alone okay
that's everyone in california
i am present in my home with my children
uh at this point christina are we free
to have uh general conversation
absolutely um you are streaming live on
youtube and everything is being
recorded so please go ahead thank you
very much
again thank you folks for for joining i
apologize for being a little behind
on some of the protocol um i did see
um attorney ogden from the department of
labor has has logged on
our attorney augustine we will not be
needing you until
um 11 00 a.m but you're welcome you're
welcome either
come back to the meeting at that point
or you can stay on
through the the meeting at this point
just
some brief introductions um
excuse me of the schedule i'd like to
have a conversation
with uh members so we can um
briefly introduce ourselves and ask any
questions you have for the next 15 or 20
minutes at that point we'll be
discussing
um the our role and the role of the
department of employment securities
with commissioner coppolis and lavers
and then 30 minutes after that
with attorney ogden uh assistant
commissioner of the department of labor
uh and then unless there's anything else
i'll let everyone
go there are some just brief
announcements
um as you know if you have not had an
opportunity to look we have 16
pieces of legislation that our committee
will be looking at this year
we the way
things are going to be handled as to how
we meet
is not nikkori nestle my choice
because of the situation we have here
with limited amount of zoom
um meetings and individuals that can
assist us
we are being told when our meetings are
going to be i have been informed
that we are meeting the this thursday
actually next thursday the 28th
and then the following thursday
uh the fourth um those are the two
schedules
meetings at this point um so i will
quickly uh get together a list today so
i can make the calendars that the bills
will be looking at
for those two dates it is my hope
that we can look at these 16 bills in
three sessions
um and have the hearings leadership has
expressed that when we do have a hearing
date they want us to meet the full day
not a half a day um so we will be
meeting these
um these three days will be long days
for us
it is my intent not to i don't like to
do it
uh i don't like to exec any bill that
has been heard the same day
um we will have the ability uh
the bills could be exact um
at any uh any of the sessions but i will
not be doing anything today
uh bill has heard um
don't just don't like to do that we're
going to do our best here with zoom as
you can see
from the screen here we are able to see
each other
we will not be able to see people
testifying
now i don't have all of the rules they
have not been provided to me yet i'm
sure they'll be provided to all of the
representatives
uh by the speaker shortly but there's
things that still need to be
worked out um one of the reasons we we i
don't know what i'll
probably like to see the individual
testifying in front of us
we don't know if someone's going to do
something off of color inappropriately
behind the scenes
which will be out there for everyone to
see and be recorded
we hope that won't happen but you never
know
we saw they still have to work on how
we're going to dealing with the cards
that are being submitted to us the red
cards to call on unfolds and how that's
going to work
um you know one of the questions that
was was given to me is um let's say
um you know someone wants to testify and
a bill and they happen to be
in the legislative office building but
some people are not
um how do they you know come on with
zoom if representative cahill
is um once he has a bill that's coming
in front of our committee will he be
able to
be in the llb and be on this
zoom call and be able to submit his
piece of legislation when others
you know possibly could not and so how
are all these things going to work out
i'm sorry folks i just don't have the
answers
um we're going to do our best we can uh
i know there's some concern
you know everyone wants to keep this
fair i've had a long conversation with
worked on the sullivan on a number of
issues
and how things are going to work and
the goal is to make sure everybody is
and we will do our best to make that
happen um there is no intent here brian
uh stuart and myself with no intent here
to
you know pull only fast ones and not do
anything that's completely fair that
everyone has
a chance of being uh completely
um heard and represented one of the
conversations we had with representative
sullivan and i had to do with
um folks online versus in the lob
i do plan to be in the llp
but that's my choice um and i have no
problem with anyone who does not want to
be there
will everyone be treated in the lob
testifying or being able to ask a
question as a representative
of the test of people testifying or the
witnesses or whatever
will they be given the same as people
online the answer is yes
no one's going to be singled out because
of any of those things but
you're going to have to uh trust a
little bit of
brian seaworth and i as well as uh your
uh your
leader brian sullivan um
you know we're gonna do what we can to
make sure
that everyone is is um happy with what's
going on and
been treated fairly so we will do our
best um
so uh before i ask
any questions what i would like to do is
i'm gonna go around my screen
screen just by how i see folks on the
screen here
if you take 30 seconds and introduce
you name where you're from how long
you've been in the committee and
anything you would like to add
to the group i would ask you to do one
thing at the end of
of your your little spiel to tell me
what is your best and worst day
for you to attend um committee sessions
so if that's okay again i'm doing this
in order of how i see folks on the
screen so i'm going to start with
you've got to mute yourself and there
you go
i was trying okay thank you um
everybody i think i'm in my 15th term
now
um been on a labor committee for
10 10 out of those 15 terms
a little bit about what's going on um
i think we got a couple thursdays
already planned and it looks like uh
those are the days that i have free
right now but
um it would help me to have the same day
every week whatever day you pick
uh so i could plan ahead
we're going to try to do that okay thank
next on my screen representative brian
sullivan
good morning um ryan sullivan i'm
live in grantham i'm entering my
third term in the um in the house
i spent most of it on the labor
committee i
started briefly on the judiciary
committee
but was then moved to labor which i
think fits my background i spent 25
years working with the national
education association
as a labor rep so
i would say there's no particular day
that's uh
bad i think traditionally we've had
mondays and fridays
um to attend to things
back home so if we can avoid mondays and
fridays i think that would
i mean if i make an appointment i
usually try to make it on a monday or
friday but
thank you representative mike cahill
uh good morning all uh this is my fifth
term
on uh in the house and on labor this if
those are
who are not tired of hearing this this
is the best committee
and to those who have been on other
committees well you're going to love it
here
it's it's a good group and we work on
interesting issues
uh as far as the scheduling i will
concur with
uh with uh leader sullivan in that uh
mondays and fridays are traditionally
offer appointments and things but we're
flexible
uh but tuesdays and thursdays are kind
of equal for me so just uh
i'll go with the flow thanks
thank you mike representative tim soucy
good morning mr chairman thank you uh
tim soucy i served conker this is my
sixth term
in the house um i served three terms in
nashua and this is my third term in
concord
i've been on the uh transportation
committee for my first four terms
and i served as the vice chair of uh
labor the last two years
and looking forward to uh this session
so
um i'm retired i'm retired firefighter
after 29
years with the city of nashua so for me
um
any day really works so i'll go with the
flow also thank you mr chin
all set okay seems to have a mind of its
own today
um thank you first off i'd like to uh
just
uh say my name is huff
[Laughter]
and uh i'm uh from laconia
i'm 54 years old this is my first term
so i'll be looking at all of you to kind
of
point the way for me um i'm
i've been a real estate broker i've been
a school teacher
and i've also been involved in the
family business
for 15 plus years so
i'm ready to go looking forward to it
and as far as availability
as everybody here is basically said the
more
notif uh notification i get the easier
it is for me to do
so if you can plan out two weeks i'd be
great
i apologize for you the the the poor
pronunciation greg and yes i do plan to
be two or three weeks out
on this so everyone can uh has time to
make their
their schedules next on my screen
representative donald
bouchard um i am a
retired uh physical science speaker
and this is my second term
all serving on the labor board and the
labor board was my first choice
because i was also a negotiator for
teacher organizations
throughout my whole career and i am
pretty flexible
uh because i'm retired
thank you thank you bouchard
uh second term i'm representing uh
belknap ii
uh which is marathon guilford talk
resident
and definitely enjoy the labor committee
asked the labor committee
as far as meeting day um
tuesday wednesday thursday are best for
me i like everyone else kind of
playing other things on my friday
flexible
it becomes necessary to meet on those
days
thank you um representative josh i i
don't want to hurt your name like i did
with greg so
would you yeah it's uh hi everybody uh
my name is josh adjutant
uh a second term rep from southern
grafton county uh in the lakes region
um first term on the labor committee
pretty excited about that
um my best and my best days are like the
tuesday wednesday and thursday i've got
that pretty segregated offer
work um so any time within there uh
works for me the thursday schedule
works fine for now thank you
representative patrick and thank you
i'll
i'll try to get that to memory i
apologize
um next on my screen vice chairman
representative seaward
seaworth
thank you mr chairman um i
live in the town of pembroke and i
represent the district that includes
pembroke and chichester
this is my fifth term representing that
district
and although my first year in the house
i was put on labor not my first choice
i eagerly signed up to be put
back on labor um for all five of those
terms
it is a an excellent committee to be on
and i'm so happy to see so many other
face familiar faces returning to the
committee
um i have been
clerk for two of those terms and looking
forward to serving as your vice chairman
as far as days go um
tuesday and thursday are probably about
equal as my best days
uh monday would be my worst but i'll
certainly do my best to accommodate
whatever
the difficulties of scheduling require
thank you
thank you representative jan smith
thank you mr chairman uh yes jan schmidt
from ward one in nashua
uh i'm retired so that any day that you
pick is
fine with me um i'm also an alderman in
uh
in the city of nashua which gives me an
interesting perspective to what the city
does
with the state and vice versa and
welcome back will it's good to see you
thank you very much representative len
turcotte
well good morning everyone uh i'd like
to say it's it is good to be back
um i represent the uh town of barrington
down here uh just a stone's throw from
the seacoast
uh this will be my third term on labor i
was in the house for two terms and then
last term i did not run
but i have returned um
i do like the labor committee i have a
little bit of a labor background i spent
uh about eight to nine years doing
uh union work for the allied pilots
association
uh when i was there i was a base union
rep of about 550 pilots in boston
i also was a negotiator there for many
many years
as well as a board of director um
i am still currently actually doing two
jobs this will be my third one now i'm
in my 37th year as a pilot for american
airlines
and i also am a investment and wealth
advisor
um for me wednesdays and thursdays are
the best days will
i tend to schedule my flying on the
weekend so i can
have the house open uh during the week
but
uh wednesdays and thursdays for me thank
you everybody
thank you representative representative
hello uh my name is andrew prout i live
in hudson and represent the towns of
hudson and pelham
it's my third term in the house my first
term on the labor committee
for work i work full-time in doing
computer security
and as far as what days of the week
mondays are my worst day
tuesdays are a little hit or miss uh but
thank you representative mark warden
hello everybody i am in manchester
and my day job is a real estate broker
and i
am starting my fourth term in the house
but the first one on labor committee
thank you representative warden decided
to join us from the commerce committee
where he has 50 or 70 bills a year to
our
to our recently 16 so thank you for
joining us i do not see
the video anymore because representative
linda d salvestro still with us
yes i will sylvester award two in
manchester
i've been on labor my entire committee
time
five years i am a realtor
so tuesday and thursday
is fine well for me i'll i'll make it
work the best i can
thank you do we have representative leno
thank you mr chairman um it's my fourth
term on labor
it's been a great committee uh you're my
first chairman and i'm glad to see you
back
i own a small business in wakefield i
represent carol 5. and
tuesday wednesday thursday always worked
good
if i put on extra staff to allow me to
attend house
sessions and committees so thank you
everyone and i'm glad to see some
familiar faces back
i always look forward to our community
meetings thank you mr chairman
thank you is representative dan toomey
and representative stephen boyd
all right i think i appreciate that
thank you everybody um i'd like to
open it up to any specific questions
that you might have um
that i didn't cover at first and then
surely thereafter we will
have the folks in the department of
employment securities join us
so any general overall questions about
how we're going to proceed
hey will has has house leadership
decided which day
of the week is going to be for session
days
you know i have not heard anything but
as i said earlier i've been cop out of
commission in the last three days
um uh representative turcotte um
have you found out any information of
what is the plan of the
uh house leadership at this point as of
right now there is no specific day for
house sessions that has not been
determined yet i think they're going to
be
my gut tells me it's not going to be any
specific day
of the week it's going to be almost as
an as needed basis but
one of the things that we were asked to
do um if any
they've asked all the chairman if
there's certain bills that are
very involved they usually require a
considerable amount of conversation
possibly some committee work uh
to postpone those um until next year
um because there's just so much we can
do
just the problems with some of this that
we're doing a pretty good job as many as
new meetings go
uh but when we have when it's not just
the committee and we have people
testifying we have questions going back
and forth
um and technical problems things could
go
relatively slow you know i was going to
hold one hearing that i knew
it's probably going to pass unanimously
with not any issues one of our first
ones out
and i was going to you know say 15 or 20
minutes but it could take 15 or 20
minutes to get going
um so that's you know one thing that i
learned from today that i'm gonna have
to
schedule a little more time um
i don't see any of those in our
community um
um but um that we wanna retain retain
and i i don't know i talked to
representative hunt in commerce and
they're not going to be able to have
their subcommittee so they're trying to
break things up a little differently
representative sullivan and i talked
about some of the same bills
the bills being of the same um type of
putting those
uh all in one day and having those heard
together so
um you know i'm really hoping
uh that this week tomorrow
it will be um much more clarity to
how some of the procedures are going to
go because right now
i can't tell uh brian or jonathan how
we're going to go ahead with
um our first hearings next thursday
how are we going to notice people in are
we going to have these pink cards
do does the clerk have to keep these you
know do we have to physically do one
ourselves
by listening to these people how is this
going to work and i just don't know yet
i really don't um any other questions
thank you i went through the lsrs and
found
about nine excuse me additional bills
uh house bills um that i don't believe
have been printed yet
um is it your impression that 16 is all
we will have i was told
by the clerk's office that the 16 that
are given to the house labor committee
right now as outlined
getting
did i understand you correctly you were
going to be at the
lob during the hearings
it is my intent to be at the lob yes i
figured at least someone should be there
um all of you or none of you is your
choice what you want to do
i have been told but i had not seen i've
not gone there to see
how the um um
meeting rooms are going to be set up how
the hearing rooms are going to be set up
how
there's gonna be plastic between uh
where people would sit
six to eight ten feet apart uh these uh
filtration machines i have not seen them
yet
um i felt i would go the first day to
see how it is
to at least have one representative be
there
i know what at least one other
individual has told me they would like
to be there as well
but it's not you know by any means it's
not mandatory
um i was hoping to just
be able to be there and give you folks a
feel as to what it's like
um in case you were
on this indecisive of whether you wanted
to join or not
representative cahill yes so thank you
mr chairman if
a lobbyists or citizens want to send the
committee documents what's the best
uh path to do that would it be just the
the committee address or through uh hcs
mr chairman i i believe that the
leadership was talking about
using the committee uh
email as as the best way to send
information like that
you know my my druthers i'd like some of
this stuff to go
through the chairman so i can make sure
uh it can and
then gets to the clerk so it's in the
record uh and then it gets out to
everybody whether
whether um brian or i or or
john can get it out to everybody or it
gets to everybody at least if it goes
to at least the charity as well as
everybody else that would probably be
the best way
for all of us i don't want to put a lot
on a lot more on legislative services at
this point
um you know i haven't even spoken
um
to heather yet um which i'll be doing
after this meeting to see how
um what information they've given her as
to how she wants
um you know how do we physically sign
off remember how we got to sign off on
these things right
we got to sign off on the blurbs we have
to sign off on on
some of these things um so
how they're going to want us to do that
whether it's going to be electronically
set up
with docusign i just don't know
i don't see any other hands um if i
could
representative infantine um would you be
able to
maybe designate a tech person so that um
i can we do have a training
um thursday morning for anyone willing
to
to operate some of the zoom controls um
oh you're going i didn't know you
okay that's news to me i apologize so
you can explain what you're looking for
someone to do please
yes absolutely um so because we have
limited licenses and
the researchers have at least five
committees we may or may not be
constantly in if they're scheduled at
the same time so we're looking for
someone that is comfortable and
technologically
savvy enough to uh work with the
controls and we'll show them how to
promote people
if they're doing a public hearing and
someone needs to
be moved up from the attendees to be
able to to do that
it looks like representative turcotte
but we're just looking for someone who's
willing to be trained in that capacity
just to make sure that we have someone
willing to go ahead and do that
moving forward i will do that but i'd
love to have a backup
because i'm only semi technologically
advanced
so any any committee member can feel
free to email me or
or i'll make sure that some of the folks
that i have not contacted
um personally by the phone i will make
sure i do that and provide you with my
cell phone number
so anyone who just feel free to contact
me with that at any time
and um and if you and then you can let
me know whether or not
you feel comfortable with wanting to
take uh take this on as well
so thank you christine christina uh i
will
join thursday to do some um
training but uh hopefully we get someone
anything else well
did um did the house leadership or i
know christina just mentioned the tech
uh person uh have they offered you the
opportunity to come in and look at the
rooms in advance i know that we were
talking about that yesterday and i don't
wasn't sure if they'd sent that notice
out to you yet
i've yet to see it okay
they they should be offering uh that
ability for you to come in and check out
the room see how it is and all that so
if they haven't you
you should get that thank you
well is this anything else i'd like to
uh see if um
assistant commissioner lauers from the
employment securities is on the line
with us
as well as uh commissioner popatas i
don't see them on my screen
but it doesn't mean they're not there oh
their screen too
oh nice job will
see i see your nice pretty picture
uh mr lavers um
there you are uh the pretty picture
wasn't
wasn't of me you were referring to the
nice lake and mountains yeah
i know many of you have been on as only
a few new folks i didn't want to go into
this
too too much
in length because over the years some of
you remember
we would spend a half a day or a day
over the department of labor
department over the department of
employment securities obviously that's
not that we're not able to do that
there's a lot of stuff going on
obviously because of kovitz so
um you know anything you want in excess
of 15 or 20 minutes that we're going to
be your half an hour we're going to be
doing with the two departments please
let us know
um we will um commissioner are we going
to have the
more often than not we are given a set
of books
and pamphlets from the department would
we be uh expecting to get that as well
this year for some of our members
with the new laws and things yeah
mr chairman we could provide you as many
copies of
that you need of the law and rule book
the updated law and rule book
and together with some additional
information on department programs
similar information that's been provided
in the past
we haven't sent anything over yet we
wanted to obviously review that with you
to see what the best
way of delivering that we can send it
out individually to members
at addresses that you provide or
if you want to default to the addresses
that are available
um on the house page um we can do that
from our mail room over here
make it easier on you i know you guys
got plenty on your plate as you try to
get everything ready for hearings so we
can we can chat
afterwards and we can decide what the
best way to do that is
that'll be fine i will let you know but
other than that the floor is yours okay
and i i know
uh commissioner capatis is uh on here as
well do you see him
to be able to promote him to did you
yes he did because there's two of you
and i wanted to make sure that that was
him let me
i'll bring him on and then i'll change
all right now i can see commissioner
compatis
he's a better looking rich labras than i
am
yeah we'll be there we'll be we'll both
be rich laborers today that'll be it'll
be great
well anyways thank you mr chairman and
uh committee members for inviting us to
meet with you today um and uh as
you indicated deputy commissioner lavers
is on as well
deputy commissioner labors is going to
talk about claim
claim volume trust fund balance things
like that so what i thought we'd start
off with
is the three bureaus that we have our
employment services bureau
which is what i'll start with so
prior pandemic we used to be able to do
job fairs throughout the state
we had somewhere between 25 and 30 job
fairs we'd have
some places especially the southern tier
we would have a significant number of
job seekers that would show up there
you know some of the facilities we'd
have 800 people since that time
we've sort of had to go back and pivot
and try to figure out okay how are we
going to
how are we going to produce uh job
opportunities for those seeking jobs and
to work
with employers who are looking for job
seekers
and so we came up with the virtual job
fears which we've been doing and we have
done
11 of those virtual draw fears so far
we've had 306
employers attending and 1077 job seekers
we've gotten
significant uh good response from both
the employers as well as the job seekers
we've
partnered as well with the tech alliance
as well as
uh business and economic affairs
business and economic affairs has been a
terrific partner they've been assisting
us
finding employers to participate in
these job fairs and then we've done a
lot of social
media outreach in order to
in order to reach job seekers as well as
email blasts to job seekers as well as
notifications on our
website in order to get these folks to
register for those job fairs
our next job here is scheduled for
thursday january 28th from 11 to 1 pm
we already have 32 employers scheduled
for that
and we have been doing these job fairs
in virtually
all industries the past four job fairs
we've done specifically
in the health care field because as you
know there's a significant need out
there in the healthcare
to me for additional workers the job
portal that we have on our website
that has over 400 employers registered
along with
over 2 000 jobs and job seekers can look
by region they
can look by town occupation and whether
or not they're looking for full or
part-time employment
we're working significantly with our
veteran community
we're doing outreach for our veterans
we're working with the adjutant general
on
on assisting veterans trying to get back
to work they are obviously
the number one priority of employment
security and we've done a significant
amount of work with them
we're also working on the re-entry
program we have staff that are working
with the house of corrections in all the
different counties
in order to prepare these folks for
re-entry into the community
uh we're doing workshops with them out
in the house of corrections and
providing them with assistance
in order to get back into the work field
we also have the job
training fund which has been uh in
existence for a significant amount of
time that's been
transferred over to us from bea so we
offer job training assistance and
the job training fund to employers that
are seeking to upgrade the skills of
their current employees
as well as the work ready program which
offers soft skills that's offered
through the community college and that
all works
through the job training fund our
unemployment compensation bureau
the contribution section is responsible
for collection of employer taxes
which maintain the trust fund and they
registered new employees
new employers as well as collect current
and delinquent taxes
are uh payout of all eligible unemployed
unemployment claims all those folks that
are eligible for unemployment claims
uh are paid out through through our
trust fund as well as
through the programs that were enacted
by the feds through the cares act
and uh they have you know so far today
we've
paid out in claims between the state ui
state ui fund as well as the cares act
and all the other programs 1.557 billion
dollars
since the middle of march which is which
exceeds the past
10 years of what we paid out in
unemployment benefits
the economic labor market bureau
provides labor market info and
measurements
of labor market outcomes to assist local
private employers educators
and the public and making decisions
which promote economic development
and as well as the efficient use of
state labor resources
elmi is a resource for employment
statistics
they release the ui rate on a monthly
basis
through the bureau of labor statistics
as well as demographics and economic and
labor market info
in new hampshire the
economic labor market bureau also
provides a great deal of assistance to
bea when ba
has companies that are looking to move
into the new hampshire
area from other states uh they get all
of their statistical information from
most of the statistical information from
us
prior to those companies moving into the
end of the state and
we provide as much information as
possible to them
with that i'll let rich take over from
there to talk a little bit about
about claim claim volume
right thank you commissioner um is can
everyone hear me okay
is that good all right i'm going to uh
what i'm going to try to do here i'm
going to
share my screen just to show
the members of the committee um what the
if you haven't seen some of the new
micro sites that we've stood up during
the pandemic that the commissioner was
talking about
um you can see um how those sites look
and feel and how they function so i'll
do that and then i'll
i'll have i think i'll need to stop my
share at that point and then restart it
to show you
a brief uh powerpoint going over some
pandemic numbers
so and then obviously uh commissioner
compatis and i would uh you know
happy to stick around and answer any and
okay everyone should be seeing the nhes
website
um this is our this is our old website
the the website that existed pre
pandemic um and um
it is uh a it's an older
website that has a there it's a
difficult
site to navigate on and we immediately
encountered problems at the beginning of
the pandemic and realized we
we needed to change and change quickly
how we're going to be communicating with
the large segment of the public that was
utilizing our services
what we have done and what we will be
continuing to do
is we launched a new microsite for all
information related to unemployment here
it is you can see
it's available at
unemploymentbenefits.nh.gov
and this is where we've been providing
information
not only for individuals looking to go
in file their claim
to learn the process for filing a claim
but this is where we've been promoting
all of our
information on the jobs portal the
virtual
uh job fairs as the commissioner was
talking about
and this is what we've been using for
all of the quick uh the fast
changing information that we had over
these last few weeks with the federal
extension you know on again off again
that was tough to communicate
with the public and there are a lot of
people that had questions
we were able to use this site um it was
kind of our
it was a george or my personal blog it
seemed like
um for those days as we were trying to
get the most accurate information
up to the public um so this
the site was launched in the early part
of the pandemic
and and again this is where we've linked
the
jobs portal um that you can see here so
this is the site that the commissioner
was talking about
um where an individual is able to go in
they can search
by region so here are our regions that
you could search by
you can search by community so this is
all of our communities
and you can search by occupational type
so the the um narrower that you have
your search
the fewer results the broader um the um
the higher the number of results that
you're going to see
and what an individual sees is that i'll
just uh grab
i'll grab exeter um
for an example um and i'll search
there so we have with just using exeter
as our
filter you have 42 jobs that come up
here are the employers along with
whether or not the positions are full or
part-time
for instance this position with vapor
therm they are a medical device
manufacturer
with respiratory technology over an
exeter we've worked with them closely
throughout the pandemic helping to fill
their growing needs
someone coming in and interested in
vapor therm they would then click
see this description of vapor therm they
would then be able to fill out some
simple information um confirm that they
are are not a bot and then they'd be
able to fire that off
to the hiring manager at vapor therm and
then that individual can then look at
the information decide if they want to
keep that conversation going
so that's what we've made available to
as the commissioner said about 400
employers originally that started as a
service for the
long-term care industry because of their
desperate
workforce needs at the beginning of the
pandemic and then we quickly grew it
uh to manufacturing and education we
have
school districts that are on there
looking to fill uh positions
um with their their needs during the
pandemic as well so it's available
across industries
and across all regions of the state our
virtual job fairs the commissioner was
talking about
if the link would work oh here we go
this is our event that we have scheduled
right now we just completed those four
healthcare virtual job fairs the
commission was talking about
uh this event on the 28th as you can see
gives it provides a quick description
and then
both job seekers and employers are able
to register right on the site
and then what what they are then
provided is
as we get closer to the date they get
information on the platform that we use
it's called
remo r-e-m-o i can't go there right now
because
it will want to use my camera and
microphone and
that will not play nicely with zoom so
um it's a site that you can check out at
remo dot co you can do a quick
tutorial it's something we were
introduced
uh to by the new hampshire tech alliance
and that's what we've used for all of
the 11 job fairs that we've conducted so
as you can see this is it's a good
vehicle for communicating out
information
you know we try to communicate as much
about uh searching for work and the
tools that we have available
um later on this week we'll be putting
up quite a quite a bit of information on
1099 forms that will be going out for
the 165 000 people that received
benefits during 2020.
so again a great way to communicate with
them
and hopefully it avoids people having to
call into the hotline which which we
continue to have available
as well so i'll i'll stop that chair
and i'll restart that so we can see the
all right and
you
oops all right
so i'll start i'll skip some slides here
and i'll go down to getting into the
nuts and bolts of what we've been
experiencing so
uh folks can um start to
see what we've been doing and ask some
questions um and i'll make this
available to you mr chairman
so you can distribute out to all of the
members as well um this first slide
gives you a a picture of what we were
experiencing
uh prior to the pandemic and when i say
prior i mean immediately prior
uh the for the week ending march 14th so
this is the
the week prior to the increase in claims
um employment security had just under 4
000 weekly claims filed
um now you fast forward to the beginning
of may at the height of the pandemic we
had close to 117
000 claims filed during that week this
is all programs both federal
and state um and we then fast forward
uh to the right-hand side of this chart
where you see that for week ending
january 2nd
we have now dropped to a little over 45
claims we have as you'll see in some
other slides and you've
might have heard and and read
um from some of the the weekly
publications that we put out or our new
elmy director and his conversations
brian gottlob
um claims have really um they've
uh they've stagnated uh in november
december
um and now we're starting to see a
gradual increase
each week of three to five percent is
what we've
what we've been seeing um so
it reinforces the importance of
providing opportunities for people to
be able to connect with hiring employers
so we've continued to try to highlight
that
um but um certainly um it's
uh it's different than the trend of what
we were seeing
earlier say in late summer and early
fall
when we were steadily declining each
week
our payments uh that we've that we've
paid out so far as the commissioner
indicated
uh just over one and a half billion
dollars in benefits paid out
this slide tells shows you the breakdown
of the program
source for those dollars
the of note for those that remember all
of our
conversations on trust fund solvency
the red line represents those dollars
that have come
out of the new hampshire
unemployment compensation trust fund so
the
the largest share
of dollars paid out and benefits paid
out have come
from uh the federal pandemic
unemployment compensation program or
f puck that top line at 874 million
dollars
those are the six hundred dollar
payments that were being paid out from
april through the end of july um
uh that was created as part of the
original cares act
uh when those payments stopped uh
at the end of july then there was a
presidential memorandum
issued that created a 300
a week program that paid for
weeks in august and the first two weeks
in september
that was the fourth line down lwa that
was the lost
wages assistance program that we paid
out 88 million dollars that was
federally funded and it was administered
through
fema new hampshire along with every
i think every other state in the country
except one of the dakotas
participated in that program
um then we we look back up to our second
line
pua this is federally paid pandemic
unemployment assistance
this is uh the program that pays
benefits to those individuals that would
not
have ordinarily been eligible for
unemployment
so those individuals like self-employed
gig workers or non-covered non-covered
employees along with those folks that
have a covid related reason
that's recognized in the cares act that
has required that they remove themselves
from the labor force they're able to
file for and collect benefits through
pua
and we've paid out 287 million dollars
in the pua program
and that's a that pays benefits
it started as a 39-week program
that was a recently
extended for an additional 11 weeks so
now
that's a 50 week program and
it goes until there's two different
types of eligibility
um the first expires on march 13th
um and the second expires on april 10th
that's where they're currently
set to expire on the red line here at
278 million these are dollars that have
come
out of the new hampshire trust fund paid
out in regular unemployment
a federal requirement
in order for someone to be paid
under any of these programs you first
have to determine whether or not they
are eligible for state unemployment
benefits
traditional reasons for eligibility for
state unemployment are temporary and
permanent layoffs
so we first look at your reason for
separation
we then look at your reasons for why
you're continuing to remove yourself
from the labor force
and then that determines whether or not
you are required to be paid by the state
program
or you fall into the pua program
state unemployment benefits have
continued uh
to be available for 26 weeks
the folks that exhaust their 26 weeks of
ui then go into the bottom
bottom line here for p euc
this is the third started as a 13-week
extension
for people that exhausted their 26 weeks
of ui
to give them 39 weeks of eligibility the
same number of weeks that people in pua
would have like pua this has been
extended with an additional 11 weeks
for 50 weeks of eligibility as well
peuc stands for pandemic emergency
unemployment compensation
so this is the other cares act created
program federally paid
that provides benefits to ui exhaustees
for the additional 24 weeks i mean
we've paid out 27 million dollars
rate of recovery with these next
two slides gives you some perspective
for how new hampshire has been doing
this slide shows you new hampshire with
the red line the u.s with the blue line
how we have been recovering compared
to the country as a whole you'll notice
that in the right-hand side
these two lines are getting much closer
that was not the case during
the summer and fall new hampshire was
putting people back to work
at a much higher rate than the country
as a whole and what we've seen as i had
indicated
throughout november december and now
into january
our claim volume is going back up and
you can see that the red and blue lines
are getting much closer
than they had previously been
now looking at where we stand
compared to all of the other states
what we see here we've highlighted all
of the new england states new hampshire
here's
the red line at 5.4 percent
that percentage indicates the number of
people that
are currently filing for unemployment
benefits
in all of the not only the state program
but all of the federal programs so pua
and peuc that's we take that number for
each
state and then we compare that number
against your pre-pandemic labor force we
use
february of 2020 for that number this
allows us to avoid
some of the distortion that has been
caused
and has been admitted to by the bureau
of labor statistics
with some of the highly
volatile labor force numbers that we
have been seeing
that are attributed to some
[Music]
it's really attributed to the way in
which labor force
questions have previously been asked
they are not
very well suited for the pandemic simply
because so many people
are currently allowed and considered
eligible for unemployment benefits
that are not actively seeking work um
and that created some confusion with the
way that bls compiled that data at the
beginning of the pandemic
that continues we we've decided to
to avoid that confusion we just compare
the current filers
against pre-pandemic labor force numbers
we do that for each state and what the
take away from the slide is that
new hampshire is faring better than any
other state
in the northeast you see where our
neighbor to the south
is located on the far right-hand side of
this chart where you do not want to be
and new hampshire is doing much better
than our other northeastern neighbors
and certainly our new england neighbors
when you look at total number of people
filing as a percentage of that
pre-pandemic labor force
and now looking at where the our claims
are located in terms of sector um here
you can see
that um in our top port part of this
graph you see hospitals ambulatory care
and our grocery stores these
three sectors are all at 95 percent and
above in terms of their percentage
of pre-pandemic labor force uh that is
currently working
uh these um uh well for hospitals and
grocery
stores they have consistently been at
the top throughout the pandemic
that was not the case for ambulatory
health these are
your uh primary care offices these are
your your physical therapists your
chiropractors uh your dentists
those folks had an initial significant
impact
on when they were closed during the
beginning part of the pandemic
but what we saw when they were when they
were
able to reopen their workforce really
came back
and that you see now at 96 and a half
percent
you see here in the middle that um
before i get to the retail you see our
nursing and residential care facilities
that's our long-term care
employers at close to 95 percent
of pre-pandemic employment our retailers
are below that um with there in the
middle you see our clothing retailers
back to about 93 percent
of their pre-pandemic employment and
down towards the bottom you have our
administrative and support services so
these are a lot of your office
type of support occupations that are
captured
in that category significantly impact
impacted by the amount of remote work
that continues to happen here in new
hampshire and throughout the country
and then you have restaurants and
lodging
both have consistently been the most
significantly
impacted sector throughout the pandemic
because of
obviously because of the need to
interact
with people regularly as part of those
uh part of their operation and um with
all the the reluctance to um go out to
those types of establishments
they have been the hardest hit so one
last note on these numbers um what uh
for instance with accommodation with our
lodging sector
where you see 86 and a half percent on
the right hand side of the screen
what that tells you is that 86 and a
half percent of their pre-pandemic labor
force is back working it does not
necessarily mean that 86 and a half
percent of their pre-pandemic labor
force are working within lodging
um they are they are working they are
not collecting
uh benefits with us but they
could a percentage of that
which would be probably a pretty
significant percentage
within hospitality and within retail
while they are back working they are
likely working in another sector
because of um obviously with the demand
for services
in those or the traditional type of
demand for those services
has been depressed and has been reduced
because of the pandemic
um now i'll move on to talk a little bit
about uh
the last two slides here talk about the
trust fund
so um what we have seen thus far
is we have 18 states that have depleted
their trust funds
we have not we'll get into that you'll
see where we where we are forecasted
to be headed we have 21 states right now
that
are authorized to borrow and have been
approved for
amounts to borrow from the u.s treasury
in order to pay out their weekly
unemployment benefits 18 states are
actively doing that
um here in new england connecticut and
massachusetts are both borrowing
and when we compare that against
the great recession you you'll remember
that new hampshire did borrow during the
great recession we borrowed twice
for a total of 120 million dollars we
were
with about 33 other states uh 32 other
states that borrowed
during the great recession and
we're hoping to avoid that as we
continue to deal with the pandemic
the the bullets that you see here i just
like to draw
a distinction between um employer
experience
during the great recession and employer
experience thus far during the pandemic
so
we certainly have seen an increase in
unemployment insurance tax rates
if i were to suggest anything else every
i know that several of the employers on
this committee
would want to start throwing things at
me because they've seen
what their rates have done but
what i'll be able to explain here is
that we've been able to avoid
more significant increases that were
experienced during the great recession
that have been able to be avoided thus
far
so the immediate impact of the pandemic
and the increase in unemployment was the
loss of the fund balance reductions
those are statutorily created those
those are part of the solvency controls
in our law
um that uh reduce an employer's
effective tax rate based upon the
balance in the fund and i'll work
backwards
on those so we had started the the
pandemic
at 300 million the fund balance
reduction when the fund is at or above
300 million is that full one and a half
percent reduction
uh to put that into perspective a new
employer starts with a earned rate of
2.7 percent
they pay 2.7 percent on the first
14 000 in annual um
wages paid to each employee so when
you're looking at a one and a half
percent reduction
when the fund is above 300 million that
is a significant
savings to employers with that level of
reduction
what then what the statute then requires
is that when the fund falls below
300 million that reduction goes down to
and when the fund falls below 275
million
that reduction goes to a half percent
and then
uh lastly when that fund balance falls
below
250 million then employers
are back in neutral at their earned rate
um without the benefit of any fund
balance
reductions so that new employer that i
had mentioned
that new employer would have gone back
to their
earned rate of 2.7
um with the other on the other side of
the coin here with the solvency controls
in statute
are the surcharges um so the surcharges
kick
in when the solvency of the of the trust
fund is determined to be in jeopardy
um what happened in the um last two
calendar quarters of 2020
was that the first 0.5
surcharge kicked in with the calendar
corridor
a third quarter for 2020
then that surcharge stayed on for the
fourth quarter
of 2020 but because
of the infusion of 50 million dollars
of karezak flex funds where governor
sununu had determined
that that was how the state was going to
use
that portion of those remaining funds
that was
then deposited into the trust fund and
because of that
and because of the forecast going
forward
and the forecast showing that the fund
will remain solvent
what that allowed the department to do
and this is the real distinction
from the experience thus far in the
pandemic versus the experience in the
great recession
is that we were able to avoid the second
point five percent surcharge originally
that had been scheduled to go on for the
fourth quarter
we were able to avoid that and then for
this first quarter the quarter that we
are in right now
we were able we were able to remove the
first
surcharge so for this current quarter
which tends to be the most expensive
quarter for employers
that have traditional flat employment
over the year
obviously not true for some of our
seasonal employers
there is not a surcharge on this first
quarter so employers are at that
that they're back at neutral at that
earned
rate um and what they'll be paying for
this first
quarter and right now we forecast that
that's
where we will be at for the second third
and fourth quarters
of this year all in all with the
infusion of the 50 million dollars we
then look at the savings that employers
were able to realize as a result of not
implementing the second surcharge and
then removing those surcharges
for 2021 that's a savings of about 65
million dollars for employers and then
our final bullet here
another significant area that
distinguishes the pandemic compared
against the great recession
is that one of the pieces
of the original emergency order that
governor sununu
had implemented back in march the
the the pieces of that emergency order
that get the most discussion
are the expansion of eligibility um but
a
um equally important uh piece of that
was that the benefits that we are being
paid
that are being paid out right now are
not being charged against an
employer's experience rating so those
benefits are going as a direct
charge to the fund so that is another
way
that we are controlling tax rates for
employers going forward
likewise our reimbursers are our
non-profits
hospitals and other non-profits that
would normally reimburse the fund for
every dollar of benefits paid out to
their former employees
they have not been charged either but
what is going to be done in order to
avoid
that impact on the trust fund because
reimbursers don't contribute to the
growth
of the trust fund like our for-profit
employers do
the governor will be depositing an
amount
from the cares act flex funds into the
trust fund
to offset the impact of having
allowed those non-profits not to have to
reimburse the fund
as well so collectively those have had a
significant impact on
the experience of employers but
at the same time the tax rates for
employers
have gone up significantly compared to
what was the experience or what had be
come
regarded as the norm of the one and a
half percent
full fund balance reduction prior to the
pandemic
and lastly our trust fund forecast
you'll see here we are right now or just
under 124 million is what is
in the new hampshire unemployment
compensation trust fund account
um this is what we are projected out for
um ending the year at about 98 million
dollars
there are a lot of assumptions um
that go into this forecast and
there are both good and bad impacts
on the trust fund forecast
that can be associated with the
extension that we just experienced with
the
the federal cares act programs and any
any subsequent extension that we might
see
um the the good um for our positive
impact that that has on the the trust
fund
is that the individuals that we have
collecting unemployment benefits right
now through a federal program
there's there's a likelihood that a lot
of those individuals
would also have eligibility or could
have eligibility
in state in the state unemployment
program depending on the circumstances
of their separation
so if those programs hadn't been
extended there would have been a pr
there would have been a large group of
those individuals that would have
transitioned on to the state
unemployment program thus drawing down
the balance of our fund
so that has a significant positive
impact on when
when we revised our forecast following
the enactment of the continuing
assistance act
the negative impact that that has
and this will is yet to be
determined the the the total impact
is that the additional 300 that is
provided through
that extension that 300 now goes
through the middle part of march um
what we saw um and and some um
there was quite a bit of research done
on this when the 600
um was in effect there are
that obviously has impacts on your claim
filing totals
when you increase the amount of benefits
that every individual is able to get
um so that we'll be
looking at to see the impact that that
has on the total number of people
filing for benefits now with that
reduced amount of 300
so both positive and negative impacts
from a trust fund solvency perspective
for all of the programs that were
extended um so with that being said i'll
stop the share
and i'll uh i'll stop talking
and open it up to questions that
commissioner and i will hopefully be
good to see you again um excellent
presentation i love the the data and the
slides
i think you said you're going to make
that available to us
yeah i'll uh i'll send it to uh chairman
infantine and uh make sure
it gets distributed out to everybody
commissioner library do you anticipate
coming forth
to our community with any legislation
having to
in security such as years ago when we
had to
you know refigure the amount of um
payroll that taxes are going to be taken
on or
is that too early to determine what if
any
changes we may need um
i think yeah i think it's a it's a great
question
i i think there are there's certainly um
now is as good a time as any to have
conversation around trust fund solvency
um
you know new hampshire is not unique in
that
the system is funded in a way that we
ask uh the most of employers
at the time that they can at least
afford it and we ask the least
during times when they can most afford
it and that and that's how the solvency
controls have been set up
i do think that it's worth having a
discussion about that be
and i'm sure there's going to be you'll
be hearing from your constituents with
with businesses that are looking at
their tax rates going up and wondering
how can that be
during a pandemic you know i you know
talked about the details of how we're
controlling that
and how we've controlled it better i
think now than then happened during the
great recession
but there's there's certainly some
discussion to be had around solvency
and looking at you know whether or not
we are currently setting
those fund balance reductions at the
right thresholds
uh do those need to be higher um and
uh you know when when we started the
recession started the
the pandemic recession we were
had been determined to have a solvent
trust fund that was an independent
analysis by the u.s department of labor
that happened in february of 2020
but they're judging solvency based on
looking at your experience over the last
20 years and what type of recessions
you've experienced they were not
um anticipating a an impact like the
pandemic
so i do think it's worthwhile to look at
those solvency controls
um the other topic that um may come up
we're still trying to get some
definitive answers from the us
department of labor
is around fraud prevention
the current section of our statute
around confidentiality
contains restrictions on our ability
very well-intentioned and necessary
restrictions that limit the department's
ability on
sharing of confidential information that
obviously creates confidence in the
system when people know that that their
claim information or an employer's
tax filing information is going to be
held confidential
um one area that we are looking at
some expansion there would be with a
system that's been created by the u.s
department of labor
that allows states to collaborate in
preventing
id theft related fraud in order to
participate in that system you do need
to share your claim filing information
we are currently looking at whether or
not the
provisions in our statute allow
participation
right now or whether or not we're going
to need an amendment of that so
as we learn more that might be a topic
that we would
look to possibly seek to have amended
into a
bill dealing with benefits in another
way
but it's something we're trying to get
answers on and if we do need to make a
change
we certainly will will have that
discussion with the committee
so you can look at what the options will
well thank you very much i'm sure if we
do any other questions we will get them
to you
and do our best to work as closely as we
can with you through the first half of
all right and uh thanks again for the
the opportunity today to
to um talk with everyone and we'll make
sure we send out those slides
thank you commissioner libras
commissioner bottas appreciate it nice
to see you too gentlemen
other than on television committee bill
all right thank you and uh i gotta see
here
through my pictures whether we have
mr ogden do we have by any chance
commissioner ogden
he is on his way over
electronically there he is on the screen
commissioner argument very sorry we're
running late but uh
appreciate uh your uh speaking with you
last week and i appreciate your
willingness to come on and speak with
everyone
i think that you know most of the folks
here that were on the committee
uh the last two years um understood that
although you weren't as active on the
legislative side um
the last session you you plan to be much
more so this year so
um ladies and gentlemen uh commissioner
ogden
from the department of labor um
and uh it's all yours thank you chairman
can everyone hear me okay
um thank you so it is good to see so
many familiar faces um i've enjoyed
coming to the committee in the past and
as
chairman infantine said uh my plans are
to be there
frequently this session um having seen
so many familiar faces i'll keep the
overview of the department fairly brief
because i imagine most of you are very
familiar
uh with what we do but i think it's it's
always good to come with a grounding or
just an overall sense of the
organization essentially the department
of labor in new hampshire is made up of
two divisions the first being the
workers compensation division
and that actually is the bulk of our
staff i mean the workers compensation
division is responsible for
regulation and administration of workers
comp in this state
uh there's a whole host of activities
that go into that principally those that
you'd be most familiar with
involve the fact that we work to ensure
that workplace injuries are properly
reported
then we work that to see that those
injury injuries are either properly
accepted
or denied as claims if they rise to the
level of a claim
and to the extent that there's a dispute
between the employee and the carrier or
the employee and their employer
about any claim we would ultimately
provide the platform for the parties to
adjudicate that matter inclusive of
formal hearings
and we do about 2000 of those hearings a
year
in addition to administering or
adjudicating claims
and for purposes of workers comp we work
very diligently to work
to see that employers have workers
compensation coverage in this state
it's a requirement that everybody having
even one part-time employee
in this state secure workers
compensation coverage either through an
insurance carrier
or through self-insurance in addition to
our and workers comp division we have
what we
the inspection division the inspection
division
deals with wage and hour issues in terms
of what we deal with in wage and hour
that is
275 which is protective legislation
things such as saying that you have to
be paid on time and in full
protective legislation also deals with
such concept as notification or
documentation
those things underpinning a workplace in
which employees are and employers are
protected
in addition to protective legislation
workers
inspection division enforces minimum
wage law rsa
279 notably and i have seen there are
many bills dealing with minimum wage or
a couple of bills dealing with minimum
wage this session already
new hampshire doesn't have a minimum
wage per se
effectively what we do in new hampshire
per 279 is we track to the federal
minimum wage so again one thing to
consider as we see those bills dealing
or detailing new minimum wage
um ideas is that
presently we track to the federal
standard in addition to
protective legislation and minimum wage
we also deal with youth labor
under rsa 276a essentially in new
hampshire there are certain provisions
put in place to protect youth labor
uh the intent of those is to say that
you know during certain periods
specifically when youth
anyone under 18 is in school they should
only be working so many hours in a given
week
and things of that nature additionally
the inspection division
provides safety enforcement
we do not handle safety for private
employers other than in limited
circumstances which i'll touch upon
our primary safety interest or our
safety focus is dealing on workplace
safety for public and municipal
employers
for private employers our safety is
really centered on the idea that any
employer
of 15 or more individuals should be
doing certain things such as having a
joint loss management committee in
effect
and also having a safety summary plan
lastly
in terms of the activities of the
inspection division is we regulate
and enforce boiler and elevator
protections
uh those are within rsa 157a and 157b
in terms of talking about i i think that
employment security did a wonderful job
in touching upon what they've
experienced through kovid
not having anything to do with
unemployment we've not had the
experiences that they've had
but we have had certain things come up
in coveter specific to covid
namely if you're going by division in
workers compensation
early on a number of questions were
coming to us dealing with this
idea of is covid compensable under
workers comp
the answer is it is um and then in terms
of well is it just an
automatic the answer there is it's not
so specifically
individuals who are able to say that
they contracted covit and had
certain either indemnity costs or
medical costs
associated with covid could be brought
as a claim but they would ultimately
have to demonstrate
that the covid came out of their course
of the employment which is not always an
easy thing to show by its very nature a
pandemic is tough to pin down
exactly where and when it happened so
that's something
to keep in mind in terms of covet claims
the last time i checked which was about
a week ago
we have received roughly 2 000 first
reports of injuries
denoting covid as the injury i would
point out that a first report of injury
is not necessarily an acknowledgement or
acceptance of a claim
and it's also not an acknowledgement and
acceptance by the employer
that the injury definitively happened at
work but
it is an indication that covet happened
and it possibly happened at work
so i just point out that we've seen
roughly 2 000
filings indicating first report of
injury as covid
in terms of actual disputed claims we've
had
under 10 hearings go forward dealing
with covid as the injury at issue
so that's a fairly low amount i was
actually somewhat surprised when i saw
that but again i think that part of what
the issue is is understanding the
the horrible things that are associated
with kovid
absent those really horrible outcomes if
you're talking about
covid type scenarios you're really in a
context of workers comp would be saying
was their lost time
were there medical bills so that's
perhaps why we have not seen
a number of claims uh that have gone to
the actual point of
uh full hearing as we haven't seen
people looking to assert that they have
a long-term
uh loss of work potential due to covid
at least we have not seen it yet in
terms of uh
inspection division and covet or in
issues that have come up in the context
of kovid
a couple of big things one as you might
imagine is this idea that in covet a lot
of people a lot of employers have had to
change things
quickly we've seen employers that have
reduced individuals pay
we've seen employers that have reduced
certain benefits or done different
things in order to stay afloat
so we've had a number of issues come up
where certain things happened
unilaterally
and without notice and while we're
sympathetic and can understand that in
the fast-paced world and in these
unforeseen circumstances an employer
might not always have the wherewithal to
say
okay i've documented that i've given in
advance
the law does require that if you're
changing pay if you're changing benefits
if you're changing
certain essential terms of employment
you would have to give advance notice to
employees
and when that's not happened there have
been issues that have come to us
i would note that throughout the
pandemic we
tried to look at things and understand
that us going into businesses
might not be the best thing for some
employers it might not also be the best
thing for certain of our employees from
a safety perspective
but throughout we have maintained an
inspection stance
early on in covet a number of our
inspectors actually
were providing services to employment
security for purposes of fraud detection
but throughout we have maintained
inspection activities and we're
continuing to do that
we're continuing to go into businesses
again being sensitive to spacing
and not trying to further disrupt
businesses but just understanding that
while folks are working
they should be entitled to those
protections um
additionally in terms of issues
reloading relating to
notifications or changing terms of
employment one issue that's come up and
we've spoken with the folks in
hospitality quite frequently on this
is tips as you folks who've been on this
committee for some time might know
tips are always a hot button issue
because the employees that receive tips
those are their wages
and there's a whole host of concerns and
considerations that go into that
we've not yet seen any legislation on
this but one thing we have talked about
and again we've talked about this with
folks in the hospitality industry
is that the existing laws and
regulations on tips do not necessarily
work very well with these new models
that have come out in terms of
all online ordering you know everyone
doing things
through through an app and limited
people in the building it's been
led to some issues where you know the
question is who does the tip belong to
is the employer able to take all of
those tips
those tips and distribute them freely
or are there certain employees in the
exercise that could directly claim that
the tip is there so that's something
that's come up again we've not seen
legislation on it to date
and i'll be quite honest i don't have
the answer
to you know exactly how you would write
a law that would perfectly fit present
circumstance but i just pointed out
as an issue that has come up relative to
covid
and wage an hour um that's what i have
in terms of an
overarching very general presentation of
what we do
in some of the things we've encountered
in covid again
i do understand that most of you have
dealt with us before so
i'm going on the assumption that a lot
of you do have a pretty good
understanding of what we do and what
we're involved in
um commissioner ogden one of the
concerns that i have
going forward is
related to getting the vaccine and
work um you know employers putting it
across from
some some things um because maybe
they're more uh
concerned with the the code than others
you can't come into the office you can't
come in unless you have a vaccine you
can't do this you can't do these things
uh are you going to be having some
training of sessions for employers
um so people don't violate the law
here regarding um you know whether
you're the vaccine to come into my store
or be working in my business
et cetera yeah one of the things we've
been working on it's an interesting
point and thank you for the question
uh chairman infantine um a lot of those
uh
it's actually eeoc protections dealing
with
in a general sense in new hampshire an
employer has the right to
to put in place those types of
conditions and by those types of
conditions an employer could say
you have to do this you have to do that
where you'd want to have some concerns
is if you are in any way
tripping across somebody's uh protected
rights in the sense of are you
discriminating against them for either a
health reason
or are you discriminating against them
for some other reason i've seen certain
literature out there that's
heightened to the fact that some
religions might have
aversions to vaccines which would lead
to a protected right but a big one would
be health or things of that nature
what we are looking to do is put
together some guidance for that that we
could offer out i would say that
employers
that have asked us that question to date
we've put them in contact
with folks at eeoc and we've actually in
a general sense said that in
a from a basic standpoint an employer
would have the ability
to place those types of conditions
relative to an individual working for
them
but you'd have to just again look at am
i in any way infringing upon someone's
protected status whether it be their
particular health conditions or
thank you any other questions for
commercial representative
representative feel free
thank you mr chairman thank you uh rudy
it's good to see you again
um there was a question from one of my
fellow business partners was um the mass
mandate working in an open kitchen and
has open flames
would workmen's comp cover a facial burn
related to that and
i asked that question of my workman's
comp people
and they didn't have any information on
that so i was just wondering if
people would be covered if they're under
the
extended mass mandate if they're working
in an open kitchen with open flame if
it happens to catch fire would work
cover that in that instance being a
mandate from the government
um i would think so certainly and i know
this answer is not always the best it's
certainly it depends you you'd always
look each type of claim comes up and is
is looked at individually and on the
facts i would say that i could see a
claim like that succeeding
when you talk about workers comp claims
uh you always have to look at such
things as this concept of neutral risk
you know was the risk enhanced
uh by the fact that the individual was
at work or
engaged in their employment in the
scenario and this is a gross
oversimplification but in the scenario
you've provided certainly everyone's
being told they have to wear
masks but not everyone is working with
ovens or open flamed oven so again while
i'm not the
i'm not deciding that case right now i
would see that there there is a possible
claim there on the basis of again the
fact yes everyone should be wearing
masks
or is being told they have to wear masks
uh but not everyone
uh who's being told that has a job that
makes them work in front of oven so in a
i think that that claim could go forward
thank you mr chairman thank you rudy
thank you
seeing none thank you very much uh mr
ogden we will be in touch
thank you so much let me know again as
uh echo alec of the thoughts of uh
deputy commissioner lavers any questions
feel free to reach out at any time and
we'll try and get you guys responses
right away so thank you
all right thank you very much i do
see representative toomey uh i i hope i
didn't ignore you earlier i
called your name when we were
introducing ourselves i didn't hear you
i apologize if you were there
uh welcome okay yeah thank you
so uh you want me to introduce myself a
little bit about it
yes please okay uh this is my third term
on the labor committee my first term was
1989 and 90 and then
last the last term was my second term
and this will be my third
i'm a retired firefighter after retiring
from the
fire department i worked for the
american federation of teachers and
covered
the states of maine and new hampshire
and i
uh represented all the different
categories
within the school environment but i also
uh represented nursing home employees
and
and and one police department in
bridgeton maine believe it or not
all for the american federation of
teachers so i've
finally retired uh and uh
uh so i'm looking forward to this coming
session
thank you oh thank you to me
all right folks i don't want to keep you
uh any longer um
anyone have any questions please feel
free to raise your hand i'll
i'll scan real quick to see if there's
any additional questions
um i will be uh calling um
heather um goalie today and setting up
some things for next thursday
i picked up some of the easier bills and
should have a very limited
um uh testimony and we'll allow for some
breaks and we're not going to go every
30 minutes every hour a while break in
the
morning for half an hour in the
afternoon as well as a lunch break
all righty uh for those of you i
haven't spoken to personally uh um uh by
phone i will do so
remaining today and tomorrow to get in
touch with you folks
to let you know uh my personal uh
contact information
and then you can uh feel free to ask me
any other questions then um
so if i if nothing else uh anyone want
to volunteer to be my backup for uh
technology let me know and
i look forward to another good
good year with the labor committee thank
you all for for wanting to be involved
and